[Music]
okay in win-win a win-win situation news
yeah
submitted by Princess Zelda good see
she's doing well tobacco company Philip
Morris is standing starting a life
insurance fund what tobacco company
Philip Morris is starting a life
insurance firm solid business like we
were saying in the other one men make
more money cuz they're con artists yeah
dirty [ __ ] all you sleeves up and get in
there with those dead people that you
kill they're double dipping that's crazy
that's ballsy guys a double bit [ __ ]
up yep that's why guys love anal and
[ __ ] double dip level business triple
dippers always trying to dip in
everything where's the third one the
math on it triple dippers see you forgot
what a mouth what in case you don't know
what we're talking about we're talking
about the gender pay gap and why guys
make more money is because guys cheat
and they're scoundrels figure out ways
to make more money and then we Paul laid
that into um butt sex
and there's the ones I right now [ __ ]
writing an angry [ __ ] comment to you
Joe not all guys are like that go
[ __ ] die anyways ok so Philip Morris
they're starting this and life insurance
business called Revit II and they will
be selling life insurance in the UK with
plans to expand more into more markets
Ohio
let's inch does your husband smoke will
insure him with [ __ ] wasn't remedy
remedy remedy yeah so they're saying
that pay it out oh we're not supposed to
shred it right okay so they're saying
that on average so for the other thing
is that people who switch to
e-cigarettes will receive a two point
five percent discount on their premiums
and then people who switch over to
Philip Morris's heated tobacco product
called IQ OS for three months will
receive a 25% discount and then people
who quit smoking for at least a year
will receive a 50% discount whoa
premiums for a 20 year-old nonsmoker run
about six dollars and forty seven cents
a month for life insurance policies
$194,000 and then the same premium would
buy a seventy seven thousand policy for
a 40 year old nonsmoker so the whole
thing here is that they're saying
they're trying to move away from
cigarette like compulsive yeah it sounds
like they're trying to get people to
stop smoking sounds like a lie to me
because I would say it sounds like they
were if they were like hey we're not
making these anymore then I'd be like oh
[ __ ] they really are trying to move them
away from suit yeah that's like a casino
that always has a gamblers anonymous
phone line at the casino like oh you got
a problem here because you know we'll
get to the phone yeah it's in the back
next to the slots
that's a blackjack table hey we have a
special right now you get one free roll
basically one phone call gets you a roll
that ensures your life
so no this is a their Philip Morris's
version you think what do you stick a
real cigarette in there Oh robots ooh
that looks like a real cigarette
that's pregnancy test I don't see how
that's a life insurance policy no it's
not a life insurance lesson they're
saying that if you use this product
you'll get a discount on your policy oh
so they get pay from the insurance but
then you also use that product and then
they you buy from them too so they're
promoting their own line of profit yeah
I quit smoking get your insurance then
though then those supposedly given by
somebody else's cigarettes 50% discount
if they do oh wait a minute
follow me here what's the scam what's
the scam you quit smoking right yeah I
get a 50% off yeah okay then uh then
you're like oh but now I'm gonna try
your products 25% off then you then if
you can get another at least 30% off
then the pain you cuz it's a hundred and
five percent off
so if you just I think they I think you
found the flan they're okay sign me up
yeah well that 5% on it sure I've just
heard so at first yeah and then you quit
and then you start smoking there's and
if you smoke enough for theirs then they
pay you
oh yeah glad I've really shook this one
loose that's a freaking nice gam
yeah so what they're saying here is that
they want to stop selling cigarettes all
together and they want you want to yeah
what the [ __ ] is stopping them from we
want us to all the money were buried at
it's literally can't get out of it what
I really want is for people to be using
these like their product of e-cigarettes
or the I QoS product because we have the
pregnancy test because they're saying
that this makes sense for the public
health because this is healthier than
cigarettes puzzly and then it would also
make sense for the shareholders because
financially as cigarette ad out those
products aren't cigarettes they benefit
from low taxes and better margin so it's
a win-win for everyone I'm gonna talk
about their [ __ ] shareholders aren't
just like don't [ __ ] smoke they make
a lot of other money then oh so it's a
win-win situation for them they want to
get out of the tobacco baby they don't
want relate to the big game dude I'm
just so glad the [ __ ] like you know
babe they'll smell good but I remember
when everybody was blowing out 400
pounds of so low like the [ __ ] steam
clouds of [ __ ] it was so [ __ ] every
time I would go somewhere right there
just like but you want to see something
probably smell good oh yeah get the [ __ ]
away from me dude just [ __ ] smoke
when a stranger does it and you walk
past it and I'm like uh I'm inhaling
your boy because they they do the
excessive one where it just makes hella
[ __ ] clouds I follow someone online
that doesn't like that and he does all
these tricks okay yeah yeah it's so
[ __ ] definitely then they were like
doing magic in high school it is exactly
what that [ __ ] is the version of doing
magic in high school in ten years I'm
going to make a cloud of how much [ __ ]
I'm never looking again
that much time how many women have I
been with oh and they push the other
zeros that [ __ ] was poppin every time we
went somewhere though somebody's doing
this [ __ ] out of here dude hey chill bro
we're all shocked you see a bunch of
oohs come you all over the place look
yeah that's popular anymore right it's
very niche so they're playing at the
Subaru car meets a Yugo why you guys
stop smoking babe yeah I don't know man
because like vaping was something that
was developed for people who are trying
to quit smoking then it just became
hobby and then now it actually got a lot
of teenagers to pickups
okay cool we talked about it here on use
before I thought they're just so like
tiny look like this like a little stick
I'm driving they taste good I'm Drive
six huh
they taste good one like six computers
that way oh yeah so that's interesting
Philip Morgan that's [ __ ] ballsy on
their part
mm-hmm what's on another company that we
can start coming on business now we'll
jump on that baby you gotta get dirty
you gotta get shifty that's how you make
the base like a candy that's like a
candy store starting like a diabetes
health thing or like oh yeah like a
fitness center or something or oh no
it's always something so simple you
think about that [ __ ] whole GAC the
GUP thing the putti thing was it the
glue your --gaq --gaq [ __ ] yeah I mean
look how simple that [ __ ] flam slide
that's what it is [ __ ] bunch of old
ass [ __ ] yeah but people are
still people are still into it it's not
as huge as before but kids are still
doing slime all the time you guys do
slime don't [ __ ] you talking shut up old
man we don't do that we do drugs now
slime yeah but they do all that [ __ ] too
it's always the simple [ __ ] you know all
your kids know that that little goopy
little hand thing that yeah the 25 cent
I still have a mark on my ceiling from
that and whoever made that [ __ ] made
millions yeah that shit's [ __ ] over
calm the [ __ ] down you stupid [ __ ] the
fittest bidders dead silence hear that
much [ __ ] about oh yeah I never seen
anyone in this room play with it but all
of a sudden community service am i right
guys
yes me too man hated the community [ __ ]
about it whatever done for me except for
hate on me you know what dopping dogs
yeah I want to buy the top shelf one
just the top of the rescue dog in of a
rat mm-hmm they're [ __ ] cool you guys
should all own a rat these were
developed for kids who had a TD right
yeah that's what the original purpose
was which I thought I had a TD after
that help me help you focus cuz people
do it anyways like either with a pen or
like their cell phone or just kind of
fit with something here you don't fit
you with [ __ ] I don't see you figure
with anything the flash been acute Italy
yeah that's why [ __ ] Aryan talking
[ __ ] it's curing diseases left and right
it's not so bad but I definitely
I'm Wiggly like I have boys have to move
touch things to walk around it's like
it's kind of annoying there's a station
I I wonder also the [ __ ] wiggliness
mr. Bratcher my back started to itch
there's another one back scratches yeah
ex practice what another invention did
no I got like no school settings I think
invented that though oh yeah we gotta
like find the original monkey with a
problem give me the domain is any
context between these videos okay
do you guys have to piece all of his
videos if you could piece together the
context you should win a prize what the
[ __ ] was this thing about life insurance
I had no [ __ ] idea
life insurance cigarettes that was like
a tide commercial again about
Lancashire's right that's why the shitty
selling those no no kids gonna be wanna
pray z-test in the mouth like everybody
tries to go serious that for me a wrong
what never tried it I never tried a nice
neck cigarette oh you've never done
cigarettes no an e-cig oh I think no
cigarettes oh yeah
I've never done a superb figure it's
kind of nice wait what the [ __ ] no it
tastes good you get the non nicotine one
it has a different flavor it's like it's
like hookah it's never entreat me but
hookahs you haven't heard the
commercials to stop smoking America
commercials like you know we what do
they say what puffs is like smoke is
exploding an entire pack of cigarettes
oh shut up monitor Issa we freakin had
hookah sessions all the time before I
knew Philip probably cuz they want you
to go to eat exactly they want ya you
got to think about the angles they have
strawberry watermelon are you promoting
the one that's [ __ ] pushing water and
who are you hookah with [ __ ] yeah it's a
social thing to do I didn't know there
was that much survive on how good a bowl
of tobacco like sugar or something
mainly shit-ton right there yeah it was
mainly like sugary stuff with like
sprinkles of tobacco the whole it's a
yeah so I'm definitely lighter you there
[Music]